So let's look at the solution to
our load link store conditional
lock implementation quiz.
This is what this code is trying to do.
It's putting one in R1 and
then it's loading the current value of
the lockvar into R2 and then trying
to put a one into the lockvar.
All of these choices are repeating
the try to require the lock
under some conditions.
So the question is what are the correct
conditions for retrying the lock?
Well, there are two conditions
that need to be checked.
One is did we actually
see a lock that was free?
The lock is free when we read a zero.
In that case, we don't go back.
We actually saw a lock that was free.
If the lock was busy, we go back.
So if R2 is zero, then we actually
don't go back to try lock.
That means that we are actually
acquiring the lock successfully so far.
So this is definitely
not a correct solution.
We need to check R2 for not equal zero.
Meaning, we found a nonzero value here.
That means that the lock was busy and
we retry.
So one of these three are going
to be the correct answer,
because they include the correct check
for whether the lock was available.
The second thing that we need to check
is if we found the lock available,
which means we are past this point.
We need to check,
whether we successfully stored R1
without somebody else beating us to it.
We successfully store R1,
if R1 after the store
conditional has a value of one.
So we fail to store R1 successfully
if R1 is equal to zero.
That means that this is
really the correct solution.
Note that these two are checking
the link register directly and
we said that the link registry
is a hidden register.
It can really only be accessed
implicitly through load-link and
store-conditional instructions.
There is no instruction that can
directly read the link registers, so
that's why these two
are not correct choices.
So in this lock function,
basically what we are doing is if we saw
the lock that was free and we managed to
store R1 into it without anybody
interfering, then we acquire the lock.
If we saw the lock was busy,
we try again.
If the lock was free, but somebody beat
us to it, then again, we try again.